good morning
afternoon or evening wherever or
whenever
you might be and welcome to google next
on air
2020 we're honored and glad to have you
watching our google cloud cost
management session
mastering your billing data and making
it useful
now before we jump in i want to
introduce you to two handsome and wise
young gentlemen
who are excited to bring you this
content one of course yes i'm biased
is myself dibo derby bay and i'm a
google cloud product manager who focuses
on cloud billing
specifically in the areas of
monetization and gcp services
alongside cost management i'm also
joined by danny a partner
so amazing he doesn't really need
introduction but i'll have him do it
anyways
danny hey everyone i'm danny daya i'm
from etsy
i'm program manager at hc and i focus on
cloud strategy and operation
great so let's do a small content check
after all though in some cases you may
have more time
your internet time during this covet 19
period is pretty valuable
so if you care about understanding what
is the use of my resources in gcp and
what are they costing me how do i
organize cost data so i can do more
useful things with it
and how can i draw insight with my cost
data that i can share with
and inform the right people then let's
take this journey together
this is where you want to be now we're
going to explore the questions i just
raised
in four ways first an introduction
or more specifically how a company like
etsy arrives at managing cost data in
the cloud and why it's necessary
we'll then talk about some simple and
primary sources of cost data
and understand the details of how it
gets to you then we'll dive into a few
use cases
and their corresponding interfaces are
visual output to help
jump start you and how you might analyze
your cost data and make it useful to you
and then we'll finish with a few tips
that you'll want to keep in mind
as you're managing your cost data into
the future
so let's start at the beginning many
companies have their reasons for moving
into the cloud and unsurprisingly
alongside the lack of equipment
management and heavy it footprints
cost savings is one of them danny's
going to go ahead and talk a little bit
about the start of
etsy's cloud journey danny thank you
very much tibo
let me start by sharing an overview
about how etsy decided to move to the
club
for those who are not familiar with etsy
etsy is a global marketplace for unique
and creative good
it's a home of a universe of special
extraordinary
items from unique handcrafted pieces to
vintage treaders
there are more than 2.8 million active
sellers on etsy
and the number that i want to draw your
attention to is that we have more than
66 million
unique active listings at etsy this
massive number of active listings
require
advanced machine learning capabilities
and search capabilities to ensure that
buyers
can find easily what they're looking for
on our platform
such advanced capabilities require more
and more infrastructure
and maintaining such infrastructure in
data centers would limit
etsy's goal and continuous growth as a
result of that etsy started exploring
cloud vendors and moving to the cloud
in 2017 etsy made a decision to
strategic decision to move to the cloud
we followed a very complicated decision
matrix that contained more than 200
different factors to evaluate different
cloud vendors as a result of that we
decided to move with gcp
if i want to summarize all of those 800
factors in kind of
three main takeaways i would choose
number one scalability
scalability is the ability to scale on
demand with data centers
you have to plan ahead of time probably
six to nine months ahead
to do activities such as provisioning
purchase of hardware
installing hardware testing them and
then running them on the cloud things
are much much faster
you can do that in significantly shorter
time frame
and guess what you can scale down after
you finish using your resources
the second major thing is sustainability
sustainability is one of the major goals
at
etsy we do track sustainability as we
track
revenue and profit we find in google
a partner that is aligned on this topic
gcp
commits to carbon neutrality as well as
energy efficiency
also google leverages the latest
technology to achieve
those goals this commitment made us very
comfortable
moving forward with google the third
thing is around
creativity and enablement we want to
enable our developers
and engineers to be able to use the
latest technologies out there in the
market
in order for them to continue improving
our platform and serve our community of
buyers and sellers
so the decision was made in 2017 in 2018
we started the migration
and earlier in 2020 we successfully
completed this migration
however i would like to share with you
and highlight some of the
non-engineering
changes that we went through the first
thing
is the change in the type of the cloud
cost itself
the cost on the cloud is variable and
it's very easy for developers and
engineers to spin additional resources
which will lead to additional cost
on the contrary in a data center world
the costs were
more or less predictable and managed by
specific folks in engineering and
finance
and at the end of the day the
availability of the resources
we're limited by the capacity of the
data center
the second change is associated with how
we purchase cloud resources
if you want to think about it in a cloud
world every developer or engineer
has the ability to spin additional
resources in a way
we are having a decentralized
procurement of cloud resources
where in the past everything was
centralized between few folks within
engineering and finance
the third change is kind of a result of
the prayer two
is basically the need of visibility with
the increased number of
users and all of those users have
different use cases and needs for
visibility
we found ourselves that we have to
provide more visibility into where the
cost
is coming from on the cloud all of that
required us
to follow sort of a decentralized cloud
budget
governance and forecasting methods
one of the way to handle these
challenges is to
adopt some of the cloud cost governance
or management approaches
and i'll hand over back to divo now to
walk you through some of those
uh approaches
thank you danny for that great lead in
it brings us back
full circle to the four pillars that
really define
google cloud cost management the first
of course is visibility
that means that we provide you a strong
sense of transparency
through our interfaces documentation and
apis
to help you be able to find and
understand your costs and your usage
with accountability it means that we
enable you to organize and allocate your
costs in ways that align
accountability and budgets for the
appropriate business units that you have
in your company
or cost centers or teams whatever makes
the most sense control
of course means that you can make costs
more predictable with tools that help
you forecast
budget and essentially mitigate risk and
finally
intelligence that means we give you
recommendations and optimizations to
help you
at core save money because who doesn't
want to do that
and so now that we've talked a little
bit about how google cloud cost
management works and how etsy has really
gotten to this point let's talk a little
bit more about data sources
hopefully you agree that cost cost
management in the cloud is very
important
let's take a look at where that data
comes from
if we simplify there are three main
simple methods to take a look at your
costs and billing data in just a moment
we'll dig deeper into each
but we of course have the gcp invoice
and statements
we have the ui and the building console
that contains reports
tables and views and then finally we
have the gcp
bigquery billing export the most
granular and frequently
updated source of data in this group of
three
accessible from the google cloud console
we have the gcp statements and invoices
on the documents page with few
exceptions
if you set up as an invoice account
you'll see these
once a month on the fifth day in the
month following
the month that you were using your gcp
services your invoice contains
information about
you such as business addresses tax ids
as well as taxes or payments for usage
made within the month
on it the duration of the invoice month
you'll see the highest level of
aggregation
of costs and products and skews in terms
of your cost information
if you're looking for basic cost data
that can be handled and handed over
to finance accounting and legal for
simple bottom line numbers
this may be enough but as they say if
you give a mouse a cookie
they're probably going to want a glass
of milk so the billing console and cost
management
is where you're going to go the building
console has a number of interface
experiences
that help you to slice and dice your
data appropriately
this includes interfaces such as the
cost overview
to see cost trends at a glance the cost
table
which serves as a more manipulable form
of your invoice
and cost reports which allow you to
filter aggregate
and zero in on specific attributes to do
analysis
the key insight i want you to take away
here is that the things you are able to
do in the billing console
are the greatest common denominator
amongst many types of customers and
companies that we serve
we realize that one size doesn't fit all
and so we're working constantly to make
sure that we improve our views
to make sure that they fit most people
now when you really need to go custom
or you're missing a particular view or
insight that you want to take advantage
of
that's when you want to go to the
billing bigquery export
and hint you're going to hear me say
this more than once
you got to turn it on it is an enabled
feature
so turn it on to make sure that you have
it you're going to thank me later
the building bigquery export enables you
to export detailed google cloud billing
data
such as usage pricing and cost estimate
data
automatically through the day to a
bigquery data set that you specify
you can then do all kinds of things with
it you can query it directly for a
specific insight
or you can use additional tools to build
and visualize data
and look at dashboards you might also
export data to other formats such as
json or csv to do other programmatic
manipulations
think of it as the most customizable
form of your billing data
now in the building and monetization
team at gcp
we take the data in and it flows like
this
we get usage at different intervals
depending on which gcp service you're
talking about
such as gcs our storage service
kubernetes engine or compute engine and
in the simplified sense
we take that data in and tally up the
total usage we've received
and determine how much it should cost
based on a number of factors
such as price discounting and other
modifications
that information then takes multiple
paths for one you have a path to
payments
to prepare invoices and then we also
have two paths
to our reporting engine for usage of the
ui
and then also the indexing engine to
make sure that we display
and export respectively now
note that for what matters to you the
export updates more frequently
taking one more minute to talk about
that export one of its
most special powers is its flexibility
oh my another hint
maybe you should turn it on beyond the
ability to write sql queries to
integrate
very very well with your other
visualization products
you can use tools like data studio or
looker
or tableau to visualize this data in a
way that makes it more effective to
share with others instead of having to
go directly into the bigquery tables and
partitions
to understand the insights that you'd
like to share now
it's also a source for third-party
integrators so if you're looking
to use a integrator like cloud health
you might be able to give them these
insights through your bigquery so they
can provide
more multi-cloud insights for you in the
end
the bigquery billing export is very
versatile
so we've talked about where your data
comes from
and i suppose it's time that we think
about crawling walking and running
with specific use cases that more match
up to your
everyday views of how you deal with cost
data
how do we make sense of all this
for a single use case let's go back to
one of the key questions that we started
with
how can i organize my cost data and make
it easier
to manage well to answer that question
we gotta start with a crawl and that
crawl portion of this use case
means understanding that we like to call
here at google cloud the flexible
billing hierarchy
the billing hierarchy starts at the top
with the billing account it's one of
your largest and most
important containers for cost data
we say that because it's the level
responsible for paying
for all the resources you use at gcp
services so it's a fairly large
container that you can use to assign to
costs
underneath that is a folder level it's
commonly mapped to larger business units
and cost centers such as devops or
engineering
and then you move on to the project
level this is the most common container
for resources directly
because it's a good scoping mechanism
for individual teams
or for resources that you want to keep
together so you can do
other things like set access policies or
label
below these are resources and examples
of resources include things like
databases
kubernetes clusters and virtual machines
remember that a resource can have
one and only one project so if you want
a way to identify resources that span
projects you'll want to make effective
use of labels
really metadata that you could use for
among many other reasons
costing your resources and identifying
them
together once you've understood all this
you can start to walk
all walking involves here is diving into
some of the billing console
changes that you might find in terms of
attributes of your data
and if you'd like to see it in a
specific way or to your liking you can
use
some of the filters that appear in our
interfaces
in cost management so whether it's
something like timing
usage or export time location the region
your resources are running in
or other types of locations or container
level project or folder
you can filter to make the view expose
the information that you need
and you can do quite the same with the
export
except that it's a little bit different
of a format an interface
here if we take a brief look at the
bigquery interface you can see that you
can write queries to find
very specific information that's custom
to your needs
and in the resulting data sets you can
see all or just a few of the attributes
in the table schema that you want to see
from the billing account
to usage to cost data right on down to
labels
but these are just some of the basics
once you have all the data
you can really run let's switch over to
danny so you can get an idea of what
advanced cost management looks like
specifically for etsy thank you very
much diva
actually before you start running i want
to highlight one thing
the console's google native gcp console
that devo mentioned
is really powerful and i personally love
using it especially when it comes to
forecasting your future spend it has a
lot of features that i encourage all of
you
to go try it however at etsy we have
big number of people using uh gcp
and all of those people are interested
in knowing their cost and understanding
it better
to build such tools to enable us to
monitor
at scale we had to rely on two major
uh inputs the first one as you heard
people mentioning the billing export
which include
a lot of the data on the billing that's
happening on google site so as people
mentioned
please turn it on if you plan on using
it in the future the second thing is
something we are calling it as
business inputs that are specific to
etsy think about stuff like a budget
like a team how are folders and or sorry
how
gcp projects are grouped together under
one team or cost center and i'll walk
you through an example of that in a bit
we take those two inputs we merge them
in bigquery then we export the output to
locker
and looker is a tool that will enable us
to slice and dice the data
as we like and i'm gonna walk you
through those details in a bit
so when i talk about business inputs
what am i talking about really
i'm sharing here with you couple of
examples the first one
is mapping gcp projects to business
units or teams or cost centers
so what you're seeing here is one draw
representing
all of our or actually one column
representing all of our gcp projects
and the second column is representing
all of the teams or business units that
are running or owning that specific gcp
project
another example is assigning a specific
budget for each
business unit again we assign budgets on
monthly basis your organization might be
doing it
on quarterly basis or annual basis the
goal here
is just to show you how we can merge all
of this data together
with the billing data one thing
that always popped to my mind is what is
the difference between
the labeling and what debo presented and
what we are
talking about here at etsy in my opinion
those are kind of
the same thing it's just like at etsy we
decided to not
burden our engineers with the task of
maintaining and labeling and continuing
to label resources i think change we
decided to keep that
centralized under the program management
team
what kind of output we are looking at
when it comes to
looker the first thing is we send
automated emails to the different
stakeholders who have
interest in gcp cost such emails
notification
could include a variety of data what we
are looking here
is a sample of one of those graphs
included in the daily emails
in fact this graph it shows the account
daily spent
broken down by gcp service versus
the budget so each column in this graph
represents the daily gcp spend
furthermore we break each daily spend
by the gcp service and in this case we
are looking at different colors each
color
representing a different gcp service the
green
is for google compute the orange is for
cloud storage and if you can see there
is
a light vertical uh black line this line
represents the daily budget
whenever a column exceeds that line it
means we have a budget overrun
whenever the column is below that budget
line it means we have a budget surplus
on that specific date now this is
another interesting thing i want to
highlight to you
once you have all of this data in looker
it becomes very easy to visualize this
data in different ways
and for a person like me who is not a
big fan of
[Music]
querying and coding glucker comes very
very handy and useful to me
with looker i can apply specific filters
and they change specific selections to
transfer
the graph that we looked at earlier into
this graph
which is the daily cost the electricity
cost
but rather than looking at the account
accountable we are looking at a specific
business unit
and rather than looking at breakdown by
gcp service
we are looking at breakdown by gcp
project
so an engineering manager could look at
this
graph and be able to track the span of
every project within his or her
organization
with that i'm going to head back to divo
to talk more about some of the
more advanced google monitoring tools
thanks danny those graphs are pretty
cool and they're informative
so let's kind of stay on the subject of
budget since you brought us there
and you're probably asking yourself out
there in the audience is there anything
i can do
in gcp to not just budget but give
insights
on how our budgets are doing and
performing and inform the people who
need to know about them
it's a great question and we do have a
little bit to help you here in gcp
in fact gcp cost management gives you a
place to do it in a fundamental way
you can set budgets through the budgets
interface in the billing console
and when you're ready to walk with this
data you can set things like
automated alerts you can set things like
cloud functions that will manipulate
your
your resources when thresholds are
reached
and you can get and set these budgets
with apis
and compare that budget information to
what you have in your usage and cost
data that you've gotten from your
billing bigquery export
but danny and etsy are once again way
ahead of the curve
they've played with these features and i
think they love them daddy can confirm
that one for you
but they've gone a little bit further to
develop strategies that work well for
their business
danny why don't you show us what etsy
does when you're running with that data
yep let's do that so i'm gonna walk you
through
three different approaches or three
different layers
of tracking the variation or the trends
in our gcp spend
the first one i look at it as an account
level
so what you are looking at here on this
graph is
the daily as well as month to date
variation
from budget so if you look at the
orange bars what those orange bars
represents is
the daily variation from budget if the
bar is above zero it means we have a
budget overrun
and some of you might be like okay what
does that even mean to me
i'll try to explain it to you so if you
look at this graph you can see in the
first
few days of the month we were having
positive
orange bars however at one point we
realized at etsy that this is something
that's not a good trend and we don't
want that so we went in and
investigated what's the cause of that
budget overall
and we realized that this is not the
best way of investing our money
so we ended up killing some of the
workflows that are causing this budget
opera and this is reflected in this
graph
in kind of the middle where you see that
the orange bars are now negative
which means that we have a budget
surplus on a daily level
and also it's represented in the uh
green line that reflects the monthly
variation as a percent from the budget
it started high
because we were significantly above
budget and it starts going
down towards the end of the month which
is what we intended on doing
you can imagine that people at finance
and accounting would appreciate this
kind of graph
because they love tracking budgets but
this graph
might not be super actionable for
engineering
managers who are interested more at the
project level
so for this kind of audience i lately
produ
introduced a new dashboard that shows
the daily variation
of cost at the project level so if you
look at the upper graph here
you are seeing all the projects or
actually the top 15 or 10
projects that have the biggest change
day to day and the bars represent
whether the budget or the cost of this
project increase
day-to-day or decrease this information
can come very useful for engineering
managers
and guide them to where to to the point
or the project that's causing the budget
variation
they might need they might not need to
take any corrective actions but the data
is there for them
the second graph and again this is one
of the uh
beautiful features with looker is giving
similar information here but rather than
looking at the project
level we are looking at the business
unit level and rather than looking at
the daily
change we are looking at the monthly
change so this graph provides
input for a director to be able or like
a vp probably to be able to understand
which business unit is spending changing
its spend
month over month all of those gives us
an idea about
finance or like whole level account
level project level
but in reality the most important part
in this hierarchy are the individuals
the individuals who are
actually running the workflows and
although the title on the slide says ron
i need to tell you that this is a sprint
this is a lot of data that we combine
together uh the first two we talked
about earlier the billing export as well
as
the business input from etsy the third
one that we introduce here is
resource labeling so why are we
introducing resource labeling the reason
why we introduced resource labeling
is that we have different developers
using the same gcp
project and within each project each
developer or
product initiative is using specific
resources
so we need to associate that specific
resource
with the individual or the product
initiative
that is using it or spinning that
resource and for that we use a specific
automated tooling to provide this
labeling
once we have all of this data again we
merge it together in looker
we are able to visualize this heat map
which shows
uh the trailing five-day cost for all of
those
workflows that are either associated
with an individual
or with a specific product initiative
also
we are using color coding the color
coding makes it much easier for people
to spot
any changes and anomalies in this case
if
a for example one row that's
representing pacific developer
their color has always been green if one
day their color is now red
it means they are spending more and they
need to take
at least analyze what's happening they
might not need to take any corrective
actions because some of that spend is
expected and we want it to happen
so now that i gave you an overview about
how we
track and the trend the budget variation
at
etsy i want to be very
clear and realistic in setting
expectations
it took us a long time to set and put
all of those
monitoring tools in place understanding
and mastering the cloud in general the
cloud billing
is not an easy task so it took us time
and i would like to share with you some
of the lessons that etsy learned through
this
journey the first one is
try to focus on one service at a time
depending on your account size
and your level of understanding of cloud
cost and cloud management
it might be really overwhelming to try
to understand
everything at the same time so my tip
for you is try to focus on the main
coaster drivers first and that could be
either gcp service or a specific project
once you have a better understanding of
those try to scale them to the tail of
the span
the second thing that i would encourage
you to do is test
any monitoring or any reporting with
stakeholders
at the end of the day you might have
different stakeholders
each of them might want different things
to focus on
so it's really important to get those
people aligned and hear their feedback
when you are doing your reporting and
monitoring at the end of the day they
are the end users of this product
and you want to make sure that they are
on board with them
the third thing is iterate and innovate
cloud cost management it's not a
one-time
action as long as you are using the
cloud you will have to
revisit your monitoring and reporting
tools
there might be a lot of reasons why you
might have to do that i'm just gonna
mention one example which is which
happened lately with us google
introduced a new
product which is bigquery reservation
and again it's a product that many users
need to use it and we realize that we
need to
reflect to them and show the users how
much they are spending
so we had to go back to our worker and
try to slice and dice this data again
to make it available for them with time
you realize you become more familiar
with it
and you are very easily easier for you
to build those dashboards
well thanks danny for all the work
you've done and sharing
what your running style is with etsy and
working with your cost data to make it
especially useful for you
i have a little bit of parting advice to
supplement that information that danny's
giving you
to make sure that you get the most out
of your cost data as you continue on
that
lifelong journey or maybe not lifelong
at least as long as you're working with
that business
to make sure that you get the cost data
to be correct and accurate and useful
so the first again i promised you i was
going to say it several times
turn building bigquery export on it's an
extremely useful data set
and in terms of making sure that you
have it available for you from the
beginning of your cloud journey
to wherever you may be now in the
present and into the future it has to be
enabled so you can
generate the data set and have it appear
where you need it to be
secondly you should analyze your cost
detail and reports
instead of using the invoice for
analysis i've heard it commonly amongst
many customers that they looked at the
invoice to try to get a better sense of
whether or not their costs were accurate
but really we even got a cost detail
table that actually mimics
very closely the amount of information
that's in the invoice
and then allows you to selectively
filter and look at more granular
versions of that data
to the point where it's going to help
you and be more accurate and active
at the moment in given time that you're
looking at it then
of course wanna make sure you have a
labeling strategy you'll really thank me
for this one later
labeling allows you to cross-cut and
deliver certain attributes upon which
you would like to make sure that there's
accountability
and cost data specifically tagged to so
make sure that your labeling strategy
has a little bit of flexibility
so that if your business change let's
say you go through a reorg
or you need to do something new in terms
of the applications you develop
that your labeling strategy is not so
pigeon-holing but you can't change it
and still have it tell you the type of
cost data that you need
then watch out for querying gotchas i
hear often from customers that they
looked at usage time instead of the time
of export which is almost a slice of
time
where you're querying to see when the
data was exported
as opposed to what was driving its cost
at the time that it was used
so make sure you use the right one when
you're actually writing a query so look
closely and finally create a query
library
you'll find that sometimes when you're
using tools like looker or tableau
but a query is the basis of a window
into the information or view that you
want to create
that will eventually become a dashboard
as that information matures
so you can keep a collection of those
things they'll always remain
useful for you in terms of making
decisions
later about what you'd like to do and
who you'd like to share that data with
so with that we come to our close
there's plenty you can learn about cost
management and we hoped that you learned
a lot from hearing from us today
but just in case you couldn't get enough
we do have another session
about what's new in cost management in
the cloud
cst 101 that i hope you take a look at
and below on the slide i've given you
several resources that might help you
more familiarize
with cost management in general and
looker and other tools that might be
useful for you in your cost management
journey
but in the meantime i want to make sure
that i thank you the audience for giving
us your eyeballs and your ears and your
time
and say this is deebo signing off and
danny hope you guys say goodbye too
thank you very much everyone for being
here thank you very much devo
and please be safe yep thank you very
much
and thanks once again for joining us in
google next on air 2020
goodbye everyone